سيناريوهات متعدده حاكت غزوان صينيا
للجزيره التايوانيه خسائرها فادحه ومحتمه
طبعا على الطرفين طرفي الصراع غير ان
التدريبات الصينيه الاخيره
واستفزازاتها المتكرره لتايوان ضاعفت من
مخاوف التصعيد ووقوع حرب بالفعل بين
الطرفين ففي ثالث ايام ما سمتها تدريبات
السيف المشترك نشرت القوات الجويه الصينيه
عشرات الطائرات لفرض حصار جوي على الجزيره
بمشاركه طبعا حامله الطائرات شاندونغ
بينما تنفذت قواتها البريه تدريبات على
ضربات دقيقه متعدده الاهداف بكين التي
وصفت المناورات بالتحذير الجديد والحازم
نشرت مدمرات وقاذفات صواريخ وطوارق سريعه
قاذفه للصواريخ ومقاتلات واجهزه تشويش
بهذه المناورات علما بان مناورات اليوم
تجرى بالذخيره الحيه في م قرب الساحل ساحل
مقاضعه
الواقعه مقابل الجزيره طبعا جزيره تايوان
اما المسافه بين الساحل الصيني والجزيره
فتبلغ عند اقرب نقطه من المضيق نحو 130
كيلومترا هنا الولايات المتحده مشاهدينا
لم تكتفي بمراقبه الوضع بل ارسلت المدمره
الامريكيه ميليوس لتبحر في منطقه بحر
الصين الجنوبي وهو الامر الذي اعتبرته
طبعا بكين استفزازا
[موسيقى]
المدمره تشق طريقها في مياه بحر الصين
الجنوبي
واصطحاله ترقب صينيه بسبب توغل السفينه
الامريكيه في مياه الصين الاقليميه فما هي
قدرات هذه السفينه الحربيه
المدمره قادره على القيام بمهام متعدده
لاداء حرب مضاده للطائرات والسفن
والغواصات كل ذلك في وقت واحد كما انها
قادره على اكتشاف الصواريخ الباليستيه
وتتبعها والاشتباك معها
وذلك عن طريق رادار الصفيف المرحلي متعدد
الوظائف
تحمل هذه السفن صواريخ مسيره وصواريخ
هاربون المضاده للسفن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات